was there a group of filmmakers that you
modeled this way of screening the film
after or was there a book where you felt
okay if we don't get a distribution deal
we're going to do it ourselves we're
going to do it this way not really there
was in some ways I mean I I was really
inspired by what the bleep because they
didn't get into a bunch of they didn't
go the normal route they didn't get into
film festivals they didn't get into or
lots of them they got into some and they
didn't have a big production company
behind them they didn't have a big
distributor now they did have a much
much bigger budget than we did but they
still had a very self distribution model
but there wasn't a ton of information
about it but as I guess it was when we
were at the Hollywood Film Festival
where we won Best Documentary our DVD
distributor introduced me to Betsy
chassis one of the creators of what the
bleep and she's just been lovely she's
been like a mentor to me and really
encouraging but I can't say there was an
exact model I mean I did read a lot of
books and I got little pieces from lots
of different things and I also it a lot
of the making of this film and the
distribution of this film has really
been happened on an intuitive level I
just kind of get this sense or I'm like
this would be a good thing to do and
I've learned to trust that and that's
been a big part of my camino and what
I've learned is really to trust my
intuition and so the big part of it was
I should get an RV and if I'm and to me
so many filmmakers are like oh I just
want to make the film but to me it's
kind of like birthing a baby and then
giving it up for adoption I mean it's a
choice to do but II to really make sure
that the film gets out in the world and
the way you want it to like for example
I mean for me theatrical was important
because I really feel like people can
have the whole experience and I and I
also can't imagine that that many
distributors would have done with
the wood the way I I did it and it was a
very personal touch obviously and also
to the the you're going there in 2008
was very similar to all the reasons the
other people went and I think reasons
why others would go as well I think
that's important for you to share your
own yeah yeah and I think I think that
is a really key thing that makes the
film a little bit different there's been
a some movies that are going to be
coming out shortly or have come out in
the past of filmmakers doing films about
their Camino as they walk it one of the
issues about that though i feel like i
had the great benefit of walking having
a complete pilgrim experience then going
back because if you're walking and
shooting you can't really have the
normal pilgrim experience because you're
working and so much about the pilgrim
experiences you know not being
distracted and not having a million
things to do that really your to-do list
is walk eat sleep and you know if you
want wash your clothes I mean so it's I
think it's a much harder experience to
try and walk and capture it and at the
same time rather than doing one first
then the other
you